ich habe eine wichtige frage an euch ich
habe eine frage an euch falls dass ihr
das erste video sein sollte dass ihr mit
mir seht gibt mir die chance und schauen
uns euch trotzdem bis zum ende an den
auf den ersten blick wirkt das ganze
hier vielleicht wie nur 100.000 abo
special aber eigentlich ist es viel mehr
als das also erlaubt mir ein kleines
bisschen aus zu holen bevor ich euch die
frage stellte meile läuft echt gut danke
freunde der sonne und ich werde gefragt
wie macht ihr das und ich antworte wir
versuchen guten content zu machen das
klingt jetzt auf den ersten blick
ziemlich banal basiert auf den zweiten
blick ist guter content nicht unbedingt
notwendig für erfolg im sinne von
reichweite es gibt genug kanäle bei
denen der content offensichtlich
zweitrangig ist aber das hier ist unser
ansatz wir möchten guten content macht
ok und wie macht man jetzt guten content
verrate euch jetzt mal ein geheimnis ich
könnte jetzt sagen dass es besonders
leidenschaftlich und motiviert bin und
dass ich besonders viel zeit und liebe
in diesen kanal stecke und auch wenn das
alles sehr wahr ist gibt es noch eine
weitere geheime zutat nämlich ein
geheimnis ich bin frustriert ich bin
frustriert und bevor mich jetzt mit
kikis überhäuft um mich aufzumuntern
lasst mich erstmal erklären was ich
genau damit meine
mai präsentiert eine unvollständige
liste an dingen die sie frustrieren
warum lässt man es zu dass fakten und
meinungen gleichwertig behandelt werden
sei es eine klassische online
kommentarspalte oder eine
öffentlich-rechtliche polit talkshow
oder das weiße haus warum lässt man die
debatten von denjenigen bestimmen die am
lautesten schreien oder am herzen
triggern und nicht von denjenigen mit
den besten argumenten frust in köln sind
aktuell wieder die masern ausgebrochen
eine krankheit die wirklich aussehen mag
aber die sowas von nicht lustig ist eine
krankheit die tödlich enden kann wir
haben ihr eltern die ihre kinder nicht
impfen lassen die damit nicht nur das
leben ihre eigenen kinder aufs spiel
setzten sondern das
aller menschen die aus gesundheitlichen
gründen nicht geimpft werden können und
die sich auf uns verlassen frust das
internet ist eine plattform auf der
theoretisch jeder mit jedem in kontakt
treten kann doch wir verlieren unsere
fähigkeit zu diskutieren weil wir immer
nur noch persönliche bestätigung suchen
könnte mich zum beispiel über in die
skeptiker lustig machen oder sie als
dumm beschimpfen und davon von meinen
freunden applaus ernten aber dadurch
gehen die masern in köln auch nicht weg
wir predigen immer nur den bekehrten ich
kann sehr gut verstehen dass man seinen
frust auch manchmal einfach luft machen
möchte und muss aber das kann ich das
einzige ziel von kommunikation sei das
ziel muss aufklärung sein und nicht
bestätigen
frust warum gehören naturwissenschaften
in unserer wahrnehmung nicht zur
allgemein bin warum ist chemie freak
wissen dass zwar ganz beeindruckend ist
aber nicht relevant ich kann ja
verstehen wenn einen redox reaktionen
nicht in ekstase versetzt aber
wissenschaft ist doch viel mehr als das
es geht um das kritische objektive
beobachten dieser welt es geht darum
wissen zu sammeln damit man logische
hypothesen aufstellen kann damit man
diese hypothesen systematisch testen
kann damit man faktische belege sammeln
kann damit man sich skeptisch
hinterfragen kann immer wieder um sich
weiterzuentwickeln ohne diesen ich nenne
es wissenschaftlichen spirit wäre die
menschheit an
jaja wissenschaft ist wichtig
wissenschaft ist wichtig sagt es nicht
so dahin wissenschaft ist nicht wichtig
wissenschaft ist essentiell jeder muss
ihren kern verstanden haben dass es
lebenskompetenz warum sie das niemand
brust von einem intellektuellen gebilden
menschen erwartet man heutzutage dass
dieser mensch politisch interessiert und
gebildet ist erwartet man von diesen
menschen auch das eher
naturwissenschaftlich interessiert und
gebildet ist
nein warum trennung von wissenschaft als
etwas theoretisch akademisches und der
echten welt der relevanten welt diese
diese trennung macht mich fertig ich
rede zugegebenermaßen fast immer nur von
naturwissenschaften weil das eben main
gebiet ist aber was ist mit geistes und
sozialwissenschaften wo ist die
wissenschaft wenn zum beispiel über
flüchtlingspolitik redet wird wo sind
die fakten und die wissenschaftlichen
belege warum kann man nicht emotionen
haben und trotzdem auf fakten schauen
bei naturwissenschaftlichen themen ist
das noch einfach nachzuvollziehen nehmen
wir als beispiel gentechnik oder
autonomes fahren diese technologien
kommen bzw
sie sind schon da wir brauchen
vernünftige regularien wir müssen
wichtige politische und juristische
entscheidungen treffen diese menschen
diese entscheidungen treffen sind die
dazu fachlich überhaupt in der lage
haben sie einen ausreichenden überblick
über die wissenschaftlichen fakten und
gibt es genügend austausch zwischen
ihnen und den wissenschaftlichen
expertinnen meine steile these nein
frust warum muss immer alles schwarz und
weiß sein
warum sind so wenige menschen dazu
bereit zu differenzieren ich wünsche
jede gesellschaftliche debatte wäre wie
der diskussion style in einem
wissenschaftlichen paper nehmen wir eine
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichung aus
dem bereich chemie
da hat man in der regel mit physik
chemischen messtechniken daten erfasst
also zahlen und messwerte was die sache
ja schon mal ein gutes stück klarer
macht als die meisten gesellschaftlichen
oder politischen diskussionen und
trotzdem hat dieses pack einen
diskussions teil wo lang und breit
diskutiert wird was diese zahle und
messwerte bedeuten könnten und was auch
nicht und ich möchte jetzt nicht damit
sagen dass wissenschaftlerinnen die
besseren menschen sind ohne ein aber wir
wurden nun mal jahre lang dazu trainiert
dazu gezwungen jede unserer aussage zu
belegen und zwar noch nicht mal mit
einem habe ich gemessen ist so sondern
differenziert und selbstkritisch und das
ist erstmal gut so aber jetzt sitzen die
ganzen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in ihren büros oder
laboren und schauen zu wie im internet
die größte verbreitet wird und sagen
nichts die sind zu vorsichtig
beziehungsweise zu differenziert um sich
einzumischen und das geht so nicht
man kann differenziert sein und eine
alte karten man muss haltung zeigen
frust es gefiel es dass mich aufregt und
frustriert deswegen habe ich das labor
verlassen und mich voll zeit der
wissenschaftskommunikation verschrieben
ich rede über wissenschaft wann und wo
immer ich auch nur kann ich mache das
hier auf youtube
ich mache das auch im fernsehen ich
schreibe gerade ein buch und ich arbeite
als dozentin der frust ist meine
motivation geworden aber war alles was
ich tue seid ihr natürlich ein ganz
wesentlicher teil der gleichung
kommunikation ist ja sinnlos ohne
menschen die auch zu hören und die
gedankenanstöße aufnehmen und die
diskussion auch weiterführen aber vor
allem seit ihr diejenigen menschen die
meinen frust in hoffnung und optimismus
umwandeln und in eine motivation so
weiter zu machen man muss wirklich sagen
ihr seid diejenigen die meinen job so
erfüllend machen und hier kommen wir
also zu euch und auch gleich noch zu
meiner frage an euch aber vorher möchte
ich noch ganz kurz etwas zu den 100000
abo meilenstein sagen weil du bist ja in
der letzten zeit ziemlich stark
gewachsen und damit hat sich auch die
außenwahrnehmung etwas geändert
dieser kanal ist jetzt ziemlich ligety
wurden aufgezeichnet wir haben jetzt
diese eindrückliche sechsstellige zahl
dastehen und jetzt werde ich plötzlich
nicht mehr gefragt warum ich youtube
mache und das ist ziemlich interessant
meine reichweite scheint zu
rechtfertigen was ich hier auf youtube
mache und dieser gedanke ist eigentlich
ziemlich gefährlich denn wie am anfang
schon gesagt haben reichweite und
qualität erst mal noch nichts
miteinander zu tun
es gibt kanäle mit riesiger reichweite
die einfach nur bullshit machen und es
gibt kanäle die
großen mehrwert haben aber eine kleine
reichweite trotzdem bedeuten der die
100.000 abonnenten ziemlich viel
warum es hier um fan ein ich habe
offensichtlich kein problem damit den
mittelpunkt zu stehen sonst hätte ich
nicht mit youtube angefangen aber fame
ist keine persönliche motivation für
mich es ist überhaupt nicht schlimm ist
dabei wenn man das verfolgt überhaupt
ein schlimmes dabei nur es ist für mich
persönlich nicht das wofür ich mir
morgens mein wecker stellen geht es um
geld
bei funk werde ich nicht nach reichweite
oder klicks pizza deswegen bin ich froh
dass ich da unabhängig bin und nicht in
irgendeinen interessenkonflikt geraten
muss wo ich konnte gegen klick vagheit
abwägen müssten aber es geht um mit
präsenten präsent es frustriert mich das
internet content heutzutage nur auf
reichweite reduziert wird weil
reichweite wiederum nur auf money und
film reduziert wird dabei ist reichweite
doch viel mehr als das es geht doch am
ende um den inhalt und wie viele leute
du damit der reißt oder nicht wenn ich
sehe wie viel youtube ist und wie viele
klicks an inhalte gehen die letztendlich
schädlich sind schädlich weil sie
unkritisch und differenziert oder
manipulativ sind dann will ich verdammt
noch mal damit reden wir brauchen mehr
wissenschaftlichen spirit und deswegen
hoffe ich dass unsere community die
freunde der sonne und kekse moody's
weiter wächst ich bin auf einer mission
freunde designs hat gerade erst
angefangen und jetzt zur unterschätzt
gemacht die ihr als zuschauer habt ich
kann mir jetzt missionen und visionen
einbilden das bringt alles nichts
solange das keiner sehen möchte deswegen
nicht nur hier bei meyle sondern wann
auch immer ihr im netz über guten
content stolpert das muss bei aller
liebe kein science sein alles was
mehrwert hat seit so gut läuft ist
kommentiert ist teilt es
schreibt ein lob an den creator damit er
sich weiterhin motiviert fühlt so
weiterzumachen
seit teil der solche der guten solche
ich weigere mich das internet
undifferenzierten unlogischen und
ziellosen debatten zu überlassen die
vernunft hat auch eine stimme sie ist
weil sie so vernünftig ist etwas leiser
und höfliche aber die stimme der
vernunft muss lauter werden wir brauchen
eine solche der vernunft deshalb jetzt
meine frage an euch was würdet ihr mit
100.000 abonnenten machen wenn 100.000
menschen zuhören was ist es dass sie
ihren sagen müsstet was regt euch auf
was frustriert euch was muss sich ändern
eurer meinung nach und was könnte sich
ändern wenn doch nur 100000 menschen
zuhören können also was wird ihr mit
100.000 abonnenten machen schreibt es in
die kommentare
wir sehen uns in der endart auf die
solche der vernunft
es wird mal wieder zeit gegen und ii zu
verteilen ich weiß wenn nicht bei diesem
video wand dann aber seht es mir nach
dass ich gerade so wie sie in dem stress
meines lebens stecke weil die denn für
mein buch kurz bevorsteht aber an dem
donnerstag wo dieses video online geht
werde ich für ein zwei stunden mal in
die kommentare sliden und kekse mokrys
verteilt an diejenigen die die 100000
euro frage beantworten wir sehen uns
also da oder spätestens nächsten sonders
tag bis dahin sicher